okay all right christina christina
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally um i am originally from
chicago illinois
i grew up in chicago illinois for a
little bit
and then um we went to kentucky
for about um three years
and uh yeah i i wouldn't say i grew up
in kentucky but
i would say i grew up in illinois yeah
but i lived in
kentucky for a short period of time and
tell me about your family you had both
your parents
as a kid um
that's hard to say um i i had my parents
for a short time
um both my parents are deceased now
um my mother was the worst alcoholic you
could ever imagine
um all i can remember is uh her
my dad was a cocaine dealer in
but all i can remember is him my last
memory
of her and him is him on his knees
begging her to
not make him go get her alcohol
well um he said that he said well he was
calling him every name in the book
and um saying that he was gonna take us
away from him
and he said plea and he was crying i've
never seen my dad cry before until then
and he said please you know please stop
and um
she wanted knock out so bad that she
took us away
how would you describe your your
childhood
my childhood was um i really have a
childhood
i i didn't have a any kind of like
regular like
continual like same schooling i would do
about
and this is no joke 12 different schools
grade schools growing up because my mom
couldn't figure out what she wanted to
do with us
she dragged us along with her on her
alcoholic journey florida
kentucky in illinois indiana
kentucky again everywhere i've been i've
been quite a few places
with her but i yeah um
i didn't know you know i've been through
he uh
she put me in situations me and my
certain situations that we should
never have been in but i still loved her
because she was my mom you know any kind
of
abuse that you went through as a kid not
by my
uh immediate planet family no
only um well i mean my mom burned me
with cigarettes if that's what you mean
i would i would consider that abuse yeah
oh okay should burn you with cigarettes
yes yeah i have scars on my hands from
her bringing me with cigarettes
um and then like sexual abuse stuff like
that
her um when her boyfriend's um
sexually abused me at my sister but
what's weird is my sister didn't back me
up when i finally told my mom
and i thought i didn't know what to do
you know like
how do you um how do you tell your mom
something that happened to both you and
your sister your sister doesn't
doesn't back you up tell you you're a
liar in front of your mom
when you know it's true
i don't know my won't believe me though
that's good did you make it through high
school did they what did you go to did
you finish high school
i was unable to finish high school
i was a few credits away and i got
because i came out here to finish high
school because out there it was um
i became too much of a problem because i
was rebelling and doing drugs
when a drug abuse start for you i'm
sorry when did
the harder drug use start for you oh
very young
very young 12.
[Music]
my mom was sick from her shoulders liver
so i would steal all her morphine and
her fentanyl patches before fat melt was
a thing
um they used gel patches and i would
just
i didn't even know what they were and i
i would take anything anything just to
escape anything and um
my sister's so different because she's
she's not like that it's weird
you're raised the same i know
strange what do you think it is dna is
it your your personalities are different
well she's a compulsive liar and
a sexaholic so i think that maybe she
has her own demons
yeah just gets it gets challenged but
mine are worse apparently
so you look home at what age i left home
when my mom passed away um because um
because uh because by that point i
i'd made a mess with my mom because i
said
you know we talked to me i hated her for
so long i couldn't hate her anymore
i told her i hate you and we discussed
it we got through it
and then we were close we were so close
so close nobody was closer like i was
and when she died nobody cared but me it
hurt
and um i understand why now but i didn't
then and um
i'm trying to hurry up this long um
um so i left home after she passed away
because um
my father decided he wanted to live life
which he should have he deserved it
you know because he got clean you know
because they got back together
because after my mom got to the rest of
the liver they got back together because
she couldn't take care of us be my
sister so she called my dad to come help
so after four years of not seeing my
father all said he's there one day
that was a wonderful wonderful moment
but um anyway
um so um
after she passed away um
that was pretty much my
just don't give a [ __ ] point
and what kind of stuff did you get into
then
well i was already into drugs i got my
mom a heroine because she was sick
because
i just got her a little bit because she
was hurting so bad
and it lost me every day but she was
hurting so bad from them
warfare withdrawal you know i couldn't
watch her hurt
i couldn't
i'm sorry
thank you and i had to leave home
because
my mom had really long hair really long
hair really beautiful long hair and she
was so beautiful
and um i used to brush her hair for all
the time she caught i used to sleep
downstairs and i
christina christina i could brush my
hair or she was hurting for
morphe christie to rub my bag help me
you know and i'd be there for her
and after she passed away i couldn't i
couldn't get that voice on my head
i heard her every night i still hear
sometimes in my head
calling my name so i had to leave
i couldn't stay i could stay there
so i just i just left one day said bye
to my dad and i just left and uh
me my dad we didn't really speak much
after that because um
he said you're too much like your mother
i can't deal with you
so our relationship kind of ended there
even though i loved him
and then he died of a prostate cancer
when i was 23 and you're how's that
35 35 you've been in l.a how long so
18 i'm sorry so 18
18. since you were 18 yeah since my mom
died oh i think so you've been here a
long time
yeah yeah and where are you living today
guys are you in skid row yeah skid row
skid row i i i'm everywhere mostly skid
row but
sometimes i go to the valley sometimes i
go to wherever i need to go
to get my drugs wherever i need to go
and if i need to stay there i need to
stay there
what is your drug today
today it's um well that's a day today i
mean
my dream of choice is um my yoga choice
is heroin but
recently fentanyl is capable of seeded
it it it's
very powerful and it it knows me pretty
damn well and i
really really want to be numb but
actually my drunken choice is probably
xanax
i love it i love it i love it i i love
it
i don't know why do you use all all the
drugs that are available on the street
i know i'm a bad person no i'm just
asking i'm not judging
pretty much yeah pretty much
i just don't want to feel what i have to
feel
my boyfriend of eight years before i met
christopher died in my arms four years
ago
that was kind of hard for me and
do you have children three
three two don't know me one called one
one knows me calls me mommy
i see him as much okay at least once or
twice a week
but also i [ __ ] up there too i [ __ ] up
so bad there too
[Music]
we had a chance to get it back and i
just
i'm just so stupid why were you stupid
just
you're you're using drugs yeah but
that's that's this is when you're stupid
it just means your
drugs have a strong control over you his
parents don't even understand
because they let us they they've adopted
him now
recently just just recently so now they
say it's a privilege
that i get to see my son
it's a privilege it's not it's been
right
which i understand because um
but i had him from the hospital
for eight months i was clean i did so
good
i said so good
and um they found out that i had a prior
dcms case from 10
years ago 10 years ago
and they took away from me
even though i was doing good i was doing
so amazing
and after that i just said why should i
even try anymore what's the point
i can't even i can't even have a child i
can love
i just don't want to feel you
so i know you
do you think you'll be down here the
rest of your life or god i hope nothing
like this the rest of your life
it would be but
half the time i'm getting woken up by
ambulances uh
we're the police you've odd before
no but they think i am i mean i don't
thought that sounds weird but
when they when they um approach us in
our car
he he's odd because they they can't wake
him up but i think he'll wake me up
i'm always able to wake up and
i i'm sure i've od before but
i mean
i don't even care sometimes
i want you because i love dean so much i
love him more than
i love myself i think do i
i don't even know because the drugs were
important
i couldn't tell you
i don't want them to be
i wish they were you feel a lot of guilt
and shame over
your situation every second of every
damn
life
every second of our damn life
that just makes you use more right i was
clean
when they took deed from us i was clean
and i just i was messing don't forgive
me i was on methadone but i was doing
good
i was doing better than i ever had in my
life
and they didn't care didn't care
we had great months and he was doing so
good
i never felt so special i never felt so
wanted and careful needed
i love to feel beated i took care of my
mom when she was dying
because i love take care of people
i can't help it and that deen was
my world and they took it from me and i
feel like
what's the point of anything else if i
can't have
my world anymore
and that just makes your addiction
escalate 20 times worse
every day and actually wow more and more
and more
i used to do terrible things with drugs
terrible things
i don't anymore but they still want me
you know i mean
anybody who says they have it is a liar
they're here with anything they've done
terrible they can get drugs
it's who we are we don't want to be sick
your morals kind of go out the window
don't they they don't even know where
the window is
they forget what a window is
and i am ashamed of it
but um it's made me the person i am
today and i i
know i'm a good person i know i am
but i have this hole on me right now
that is just
something i can't shake and i want to
get a dream and
every time i want to go i [ __ ]
fail i fail yeah i've seen it a million
times
it's not just you i do know
but in my life it is the same
because dino deserves better than this
he deserves a mother like you shouldn't
i mean
when i hear that boy call me mom
my world melts
i'm sorry
thank you
i've never had i had three kids and i've
never had one of them call me mom my
sister
the one that's alive has my first son
logan and my second son gave up for
adoption
when um dean i had
i get i i gave i was a methadone i got i
did everything i was supposed to do and
they still took it
she still took it from me
and then when they took it from me and
said we're not going to give you
parental rights we're not even going to
give you a chance to get parental rights
i thought i was going to kill myself
but they did they still blew i still
blew it
what do you think people that don't do
drugs don't understand about
addiction
how hard it is to stop
and what does your mind
and then you i care somewhat my family
doesn't even talk to me anymore nobody
in my life doesn't really talks to me
more because of my addiction
and i just wish they would
i just want their support if i had a
little bit of support
maybe i could have some kind of help
but i have no family none
chris says his family is my family it's
not i don't have a family
my parents are dead my sister's dead
my boyfriend eight years is dead people
die around me a lot
for whatever reason and then people so
much become a murderer
because it's just insane
i just can't believe why people would
think that you know
even people that do drugs think that
i've killed my boyfriend
of eight years
someone that i devoted my life to
why would i hurt him why
but that just follows me around just to
punish me for whatever i did in my past
life i guess i have no
but i know i suffer for it
i suffer for what i do
and i want to stop
i don't would be sick but most of all i
don't want to feel
i don't want to feel what i have to feel
my nose can help me
the pain that's coming i know it's going
to be very very difficult for me to deal
with
because losing my dad that was that was
the that was almost as hard
as losing my mom because i was here in
california and he was in illinois
and my my sister when she was alive she
called me
crying so i can't tell her my
stepmom got on the phone said your dad
passed away
and he was 48. so i was expecting that
it was totally sudden my mom hers wasn't
my dad
totally son i never had to say goodbye i
never say
sorry i never just say i love you
i never say i'm sorry i wasn't being a
terrible daughter
but um
he was a pastor so hopefully
hopefully some were forgiving me
i hope but um
after he died my sister said i'll call
you in a few days
and i'll buy you a plane ticket you need
closure you need to come to the funeral
i never got the call i never got the
closure i never got the call
i got i got
discontinued from the family completely
my sister she compulsively like i said
she told my
my family that i was too busy doing
drugs in california
to come to my father's funeral
so i i was unable to make it to his
funeral
and get the closure that i thought that
i needed
and she promises she called me but i
know she didn't because i waited in bed
for days for a call and it never gone
do you think that anything from your
childhood like your mom's alcoholism
might have oh yeah set you on this path
oh yeah like that like your your drug
addiction is kind of a
inherited trait you got from your mom
perhaps
yeah but wait why is submit that it's
just gonna
yeah why do i have to get it
nobody else has it just me christina
the big loser christina
that nobody calls nobody carries the
checkup on
they're waiting here and i'm dying i'm
dead you know that's all they're waiting
for
they do it
what's your biggest regret not not to
like spread the shame no
my biggest regret is um
maybe his biggest regret is um
is moving to california
even though i started using china white
when i was in illinois i feel like i
could have
the drugs are more available here no
they're way more available out there but
they're right oh yeah they scream on
those
they're on the street corners rocks
blows rocks blows yeah they're way more
available out there but
i could be with my family
more and maybe had more support i mean
they tried really hard they
did and i just said
i just said you know what you know i
don't
want your help i don't need it
but i did i didn't need it and i threw
it away
and now i'm just close to a box
you know
i don't care that's the worst part you
know
i only care for dean because i don't
want to not have a mom but i figure he
doesn't have a mom
he has chris's mom chris is his new mom
i'm done christina what would you say is
the most important lesson you've learned
in your life
the most important lesson i've learned
is that
you don't need substances
to make you happy
you just need people
that's my listen all right christina
well thank you so much for sharing your
story
i'm so sorry great to meet you no i was
sorry you're so sorry feels better right
he does good
you